[Music]
that was the scene when I read it I was
just like I can't wait to see Letty
fighting I was like oh that's me she's
kicking my ass this is amazing good
morning sunshine you gotta be kidding me
we have a nice one-on-one battle she's a
tough cookie so we'll see what happens
you're welcome we had to take this fight
and make it the best fight that ever was
in The Fast and Furious franchise it was
like you have two live fighting each
other this vital story you have Charlize
who doesn't want to fight and Michelle
really want to kill the Charlize letty's
pretty angry in this scene sometimes I
was like they're really going to fight
when you see Michelle strike the first
time it's an explosion now is that so
hard
Michelle Rodriguez sells action with her
body with her eyes you just believe it
she's so badass even when we train her
she surprises she's like a crazy cat you
know she go in all the directions I'd
stay down if I was you when you see
Charlize Theron walk towards you and
look you straight into your eyes it
makes you feel very small she has so
much Soul she's a monster to battle with
I gotta say Obviously Cipher is very
technical she's very well trained lety's
more of a street fighter her power comes
from the heart so it's interesting to
see the two fighting styles go at it
together
there were moments where she'd come at
me and I got scared I was like
each other but they scare me even more I
mean the two of them together when they
do this and I'm like cut and they turn
to me I'm like okay
ladies easy can you take one note yes
this is the fight that the audience has
been waiting for since
2017. and wow does it deliver
foreign
[Music]